So this allows us to
now do the computation.
And now let's look at few curves.
Now here I'm just going to show you some
curves from a different set of images,
not these, but
just this is just to prove a point.
Here basically you see the four curves.
This one is for green.
This is for red.
For blue and, and
then all three of them combined to rgb.
This is to point out that we can
actually do this analysis separately for
all of the different channels and
then combine it separately.
Again just showing you six images.
Number of images increases,
we can actually do this.
Most of the time for simple,
smaller hand-held cameras.
They only take about two or
three images.
Higher end cameras and
using functions like bracketing
you can actually capture
a lot more of these images.
So that basically is the capital
P in my previous equation